yeah talk about today mark um
i've been speaking a little bit about i
spoke a little bit about you know
the good side of being a gang member i
spoke a little bit about
in other ones about the bad side of
being a gang member i've spoken about
being set up by women i've spoke about
uh
you know a little bit about prison you
know i mean as much as i could put out
there you know uh
today i'm gonna speak about you know
mainly me and
uh my family you know where i come from
and you know what they're about you know
i
mean
how they came about in my hood you know
how deep they were at one time
we we were all together when we're all
like
just that age where everybody was in
other words messing around you know well
first of all you know i think my first
memories of
of the gang thing was um i remember my
father was watching the news one time
and he went to teach
he was on it was eyewitness news and i
looked and i see my grandmother on the
news
my uncles you know what i mean a couple
of my homies older homies you know and i
was like what's my grandma doing on the
news you know
what's she doing you know well at that
time you know my grandmother
she was out there running around in
different hoods there was a lot of gang
violence going on and what they were
forming was they were forming some type
of a thing that was called them united
parents
you know they were like all the gang
members parents would get together and
they had a softball league and they used
to sell you know
snow cones and hot dogs you don't mean
but it was all you know uh
gang you know related it was all you
know everybody had to be gang
affiliation to
do that you know and i remember you know
my sister and brother you know
they used to be a little older than me
and my little brother so i just see him
get up and get dressed you know and
i knew exactly where they were going and
i used to remember man i can't wait
i can't wait you know so i can wear my
pants like my brother you know
or sit there and iron my pants for hours
like my brother you know and listen to
the
oldies while i'm ironing you know and
[ __ ] like that
you know the homies calling you know and
he's you know talking to homies and
he's telling you my homie stories and
i'm listening to the stories about him
telling you know and
i'm looking at my brother like you know
he's he's like he's like superman you
know
all the stories he told me he like never
got punched in you know he
always used to be the guy you know break
somebody off and you know
i had to see my brother in action before
i really realized that yeah he was that
guy you know i
you know i today maybe we're gonna talk
for the simple fact that you know uh we
just don't
come to common ground you know we just
can't get on common ground you know
ever since i beat him up when i was like
15 and i've beat him up ever since
he can't accept this so you know he
always wants to fight and beat me up and
i think i'm just gonna allow him to
whoop my ass one good time and then
maybe he'll stop you know
but i don't know but you know i used to
watch him and
my brother used to wear pinstripe zoot
suit
he used to wear charlie brown's uh hush
puppies he used to wear uh
wingtips you know what i mean uh
everything's
frisco's ben davis you know pendleton's
flannels
he used to wear london fog coats you
know anywhere what everything was called
you know
you know me that's where the girls just
were two tops and you know daisy dukes
back at that time they were like
jordan's jeans you know uh
he used to wear you know the black uh uh
they were like black
um what can i call them like rubber
bands you know used to put them on their
fingers you know i mean and cross them
you know i mean they always have a
little tattoo either across or you know
a dot or three dots you know
they used to wear their hair real high
like i am you know and you know i missed
you see my sister you know she was one
of my most
she was one of my finest homegirls at
her time you know i think she was the
finest at that time
but uh you know a lot of dudes were
honored i should see my homie's honor
and [ __ ] you know what i mean and
you know uh i share stories about her
and my brother you know i'm like my
answers to call from
you know the hood and and call my father
and tell my father hey your daughter's
over here all pcp'ed out you know
i'd go with my father in the car and
i'll see my sister you know all pcp'd
out you know i don't know where she's at
you know i mean
she's holding on to a fan she's been
there like three hours you know
you know i never heard my dad tell her
anything you know tell you the truth you
know
my dad was like somebody like i am today
you know i don't lie to my kids i
tell my kids you know everything i do
you know not
not bad bad [ __ ] but i mean i don't hide
nothing from them because i don't want
someone else to tell them and then
they ask me and then they turn around
and tell me why why did you lie
why couldn't you just tell me you know
so i'm pretty upfront with my kids and
that's the way my father was you know
because he used to go get my sister and
she'd be
man all angel dust out i'm talking about
back then the angel dust you know
it'd make you do some crazy [ __ ] you
know what i mean and it was called a
kukui dust they called it kakui dust i
remember
it's only ten dollars for a little
tenfold folded up you know you got about
three joints out of there but it was
good [ __ ] you know
you know and uh i when i seen that i was
like
oh man i see my one of my uncles
slinging it and i seen the big
stack of money he had i was like oh man
i can't wait until i get that
age and you know i'm going to cook me up
something like he does you know because
i watched him
and he didn't teach me i i actually
watched him where when i became like 13
14 i
cook my own [ __ ] you know i get my own
leaves get my own juice
you know with the refrigerator you know
and i'll do my thing and cook me up some
angel dust you know what
i'll take it to the parties and i roll
about 10 joints and have 10 angel just
joints and you know i was i was [ __ ]
up but i just do it you know i'll send
the joints in there and let everybody
smoke it and then i'll
slip a couple angel dust joints in there
you know what i mean i see some of the
people be like
what is this you know an awesome new
kind of weed you know some new [ __ ] that
came over season
i'll give them some [ __ ] that story
the next thing you know man
they're all [ __ ] up you know they
don't know what to do they know where to
go you know they're
parked in front of the house in their
car like for [ __ ] four or five hours
you know
their money's gone everything's gone
already you know everybody walked away
with everything because they're so
pcp'd out that you know i would see this
all the time you know i'd see my
homegirls and homeboys in the front of
my grandmother's house we would go over
and visit
i mean there'd be like 20 of them you
know what i mean 15 20 of them and
and they're all you know they got guns
they got drugs they got dope and
they weren't hiding anything so you know
i remember you know uh
me and my cousins we used to play you
know i mean and we used to you know
used to play gangsters you know nobody
was a cop you know and i was like
what the [ __ ] there was some you know
when i used to go up and see things i
seen kids that
wanted to be cops you know not one
family member of mine wanted to be a cop
not one you know it wasn't going to
happen you know
and then you know and that's kind of odd
because you know
always in the family there's somebody
that is in law enforcement and now one
of my family members is in law
enforcement i think the closest thing to
it is
one's a lawyer and one's a border patrol
agent
but no cops man no cops you know and i
strip out cause i had a lot of cousins
we're all young you know what do you
want to be what do you want to do
everybody wanted to be against a cholo
you know everybody want to be a cholo
so you know in my head in my thoughts i
knew where i was going i knew exactly
what was going to happen how it's going
to go down you know it
i remember when when when i broke the
cycle with my grandmother you know
because she was on me
no you're not going to be from the hood
no you can do something else you know
and i was telling her grandma come on
man it's coming you know it's coming in
and she's being all just you want to do
something else and i was like
no i already knew what i was destined to
be you know i already knew what was
gonna happen you know i knew i was
wasn't
gonna get jumped in you know i knew that
you know i mean i also knew that i was
gonna jump gang of [ __ ] in
i knew that you know you know you know
uh
as as i was growing up you know when i
watched
my uncles do their thing you know i used
to just copy exactly what they did you
know if they were selling bud
i'd watch them put the butt in baggies
how much they would put in there i'd
watch you know where they get
where they go buy the baggies at you
know what i mean i'll even watch what
homie's giving him the bud you know what
i mean because
you know i want as soon as i got you
know i was about 11 12 but as soon as i
got like 14 15 year old
i was going to take over the operation
you know i was just going to take it
over and
and uncle got mad oh well you know i did
it to him you know what i mean after i
got of age you know they had a quote
going on and i just stepped right in
there you know and
when i stepped right in there i took it
over man i was maybe like
but he's 16 you know and i hear a lot of
dudes tell stories about oh yeah when i
was 50 60 i had my own house
i'm going to tell you when i was 16 yes
i had my own house
i was i wasn't buying anything but i was
paying 1300
rent and i was only 16 years old you
know and i just remember people used to
come over and ask who's house it was and
not they'd say it's mine you know those
people give me a look like
you know what the [ __ ] up with this
kid you know because i was you know
really young you know maybe a little
facial hair but
you know my house is fairly nice you
know we talk about french windows you
know
patio deck you know all that good [ __ ]
you know big old garage you know i mean
just
a [ __ ] nice ass pad you know big old
front yard and
i remember the looks people used to give
you know they were all
different you know i remember the one my
mother-in-law gave me you know
you know she gave me a look like man
you're [ __ ] too much man you know cuz
she knew what was going on you know i
mean you know she knew that i had
gang of homies living in there you know
what i mean we used to be like seven
guys seven girls you know living in my
house
all my homies and home girls you know we
just live in there man
you know and i was only sorry about that
was only 16 man and
you know i was paying the rent getting
it paid you know what i mean you know
a car i didn't really trip on a car you
know because my uncle's in the ants they
had cars you know and i take off in
their [ __ ] you know
they'd get mad but i mean [ __ ] i only
drove around the park you know i mean
that was a big thing in my hood the park
you know it's called
nietospark you know it's got a name of
another hood but
you know it's our park you know and i
remember you know when i was younger i
used to go play in the park you know
i just watched my homies playing
horseshoes and you know sitting drinking
and [ __ ]
and i was like man i just tell my
cousins man i can't wait to go over
there you know i can't wait to have a
car like that or i can't wait to carry a
gun like him you know and
i just hear my cousins run by really
young you know oh
i'm doing a drive-by and i said like oh
my god you know my little cousin is like
eight seven years old talking about he's
doing a drive-by you know and i was like
you know he was following in in mine and
my cousins that are my age footsteps you
know and they were the next ones coming
you know
and i was like [ __ ] it's just a cycle
you know i was like the third fourth
cycle
they're the fifth one you know when i
hear stuff like that you know running
behind me i'm gonna shoot you i'm gonna
give you i'm gonna do a drive-by like oh
my god you know what what this little
boy is saying you know
i'm gonna do a drive by no kid you know
that's how you're supposed to do you
know
but it they had it in their head you
know that the drive-by was like
okay because so many people were doing
them i guess you know kids
looked at it like whoa that was
something really you know big you know
and to me it wasn't [ __ ] you know i mean
anybody could drive by and [ __ ]
unload two clips and hit the wrong house
you know come on you know what i mean
anybody could do that you know what i'm
saying they say any punk and pull the
trigger you know
i believe that but then again you know
uh
you know a couple of couple guys i've
seen get caught
got a trigger and they push it you know
what i mean you know what happens some
people haven't some people
don't you know you know and you know
everybody's different you know
everybody's different you know i used to
watch my homies at got in the hood when
they were like
15 16. you know and i was already 15 16
but i already have been from the hood
like five years you know and these dudes
are barely getting in you know
i'd see them go from one person and turn
into somebody totally different you know
and
not anybody bad but you know just
somebody that
you know took this guy off the streets
you know there's one dude that
he's my homeboy now you know and i
remember i
did something and he was in the back
seat you know
and uh you know you that played the game
you know what i'm talking about he was
in the back seat
and that was that wasn't no that wasn't
right it wasn't
it was supposed to go down like that you
know and i remember you know
i thought man you know poor guy you know
he's the wrong place at the wrong time
you know he should just
fake like he was still asleep you know i
guess he was asleep in the backseat or
something but
i remember man i told my homie like you
know i'm
always like ah man we talking about my
little friend i'm like
i don't know your friend my friend you
know
my homie talked me out of it man you
know he had to push me away and [ __ ]
he left and lo and behold man went to
prison got out and
walked in the room and my homeboy was
sitting right there man the same guy you
know that i was gonna
you know probably harm him to the
fullest you know and
then i wasn't gonna have a sick thought
about it you know
i couldn't have him there you know but i
see him now and you know
i see when i see the first time i smiled
at him you know and he's not to say
anyone like that because you know he
he you know he was he was there you know
and he's my little homie now you know
i tripped out you know because he [ __ ]
like that happens you know some other
guys that i knew went to school with man
good friends of mine man i'll sing
there on the other side you know i see
them flipping me off and [ __ ] i'm like
wow you know what damn school you were
cool as [ __ ] you know
now you went to the other side and you
know you want to act like a [ __ ] you
know
it's okay you know i end up catching
them beating them up anyways
and that was another thing you know they
pushed on my family you know
to come from these you know a lot with
these you know
and we should do that a lot you know a
lot of my cousins and brothers we fight
a lot of people
you know and beat up a lot of people you
know and we used to just be known to
beat [ __ ] up
you know just beat him up and that was
it you know and it felt pretty good you
know
you know when you shoot somebody you
can't really feel nothing because
you can't go around and brag about it
you know when you beat somebody up
everybody knows you beat them up so you
know you
you got you got kind of more a little
bit more stripes than actually shooting
somebody because you're somebody you
want to say [ __ ]
but you know you beat somebody up you
can sell yeah i beat that fool up
you know there's a lot of dudes i see
you know on the streets and [ __ ] i beat
up before you know i
i don't hold no grudges or anything you
know but
you know i i i was just talking about my
family because we're so intertwined
in in the gang like that you know there
was no calling cops
there's no telling there's a couple
recipes just
[ __ ] up you know name nothing nothing
you tell them [ __ ]
my grandmother instilled this don't say
[ __ ] you know and that's what we did i
say [ __ ] you know
that was instilled as young kids you
know and
man you know i could see just you know
your average mom and father you know
turn around and tell your kids hey don't
you ever tell don't be a rat and you
know the kid look at him like god damn
you know i already knew what to write
well i already knew what cinching was
you know
at a young young age you know and you
know i was i was i was
put under a microscope you know what i
mean like boom you know
he's gonna be a game ever you know and
we're gonna we're gonna do just like
this you know and
you know they led me through it you know
i mean and it was a rough road it was a
rough [ __ ] road you know i shared a
lot of [ __ ]
you know on these channels you know a
lot of [ __ ] and i still have a lot more
[ __ ] to share you know me but
you know i just wanted to give you a
little something about myself about me
you know
the the lifestyle that i i really didn't
have a choice
to choose you know some people say i did
but
nah because i don't want to be the only
one that wasn't rolling with my cousins
and my brothers you know they're all
gang members they're going to [ __ ]
gang fighting on it and i'm going to sit
back and just kick it
you know stay back with the women the
children were safe nah i don't want to
be that guy you know
so you know i jumped right in and i
remember my grandfather he didn't know
man for a long time
you know man when he found out all man i
broke his heart you know
i was [ __ ] up but you know i he he he
he knew it was bound to take place
eventually you know i
got everybody cousins and everything man
they're all pulling from every direction
you know and
you know when you got cousins you know
and and
and you're from a hood you know and
there's like 10 of you you know
you could move mountains like that man
you know [ __ ] gets done you know
you're not worried about your cousin
running on you because if he runs on you
back homies get his ass [ __ ] up so he
ain't not gonna run you know
i used to hate it when me and my cousin
get caught yeah he ain't my big old
fools and
i'm running [ __ ] them you know me i'm
running i i'll run him i couldn't get
caught but
you know i can go back for him and [ __ ]
but i just hate that you know
to be honest with you you know i mean we
can outrun these guys you know he don't
want to run
he wants to fight i gotta stay in fight
fight i wanna get beat up bigger
[ __ ] you know
but i had to stay or i will get beat up
you know what i mean that was another
part of life you know
being a gang member your whole family
you know that you don't leave nobody
behind you beat the [ __ ] up when you get
home you know
you get really beat up you know people
bad you know everybody's gonna watch
anyone say [ __ ] you know
don't leave alone that's too much none
of that
no they just watch you get your ass
whipped you know and that's
another thing with you know living the
gang life and having family in a gang
life
saying you know what uh you know when
growing up in my family you know
as i watched everybody get older and
some go to jail
you know some would have terrible
accidents
you know like a staggered shot you know
you know different things
you know those were the only things that
that kind of
stopped me from moving so quick was [ __ ]
i don't have to get shot i'm gonna have
to go to jail you know
wow you know i got to do all that and
all that happened you know it all
happened it all took place you know and
some of the things i was like oh i
couldn't you know i couldn't stomach
them you know i'm like man
[ __ ] i'm gonna go through this you know
and you know my nephew just recently
shared with me
that he went to prison you know and i
didn't even know
you know i didn't even know and you know
it
what he told me this is exactly what he
told me he said
when he went to prison he had never been
to jail before he went straight to
prison
first time everything he said he got a
reception he was sitting there for like
a month
he started stretching real hard and then
he said nah [ __ ] that
you know if my uncle johnny could do it
my uncle ruben could do it and my cousin
would
do it i could do it damn when he told me
that i was like
oh my god i mean what the [ __ ] you don't
mean
where does where'd that come from you
know he felt that he could do the time
just because we've all did time so he's
built for that
he's breaded for that you know he's cut
from that certain clock you know
that's what we're told you know we're
[ __ ] the last of a dying breed you
know
but we cut from a certain clock that you
know we're just it was different and
it's okay to be different you know
but when he told me that he told me that
recently and
it [ __ ] it kind of took me for a spin
because
you know he actually trained his mind to
do time
just by his uncle's doing time you know
and he knew we're doing years he went he
did two years in it
we knew he knew we did over five you
know a couple of times and but he said
that's where he motivated himself
he used me my past experience and my
brother's past experience and my cousins
to motivate himself so that he can do
his time you know
and in a way that's good
but in many other ways oh that's bad
that's really bad you know because
anybody thinks i'll go to prison again
oh wow so what
you know you can't have that attitude
you know i don't have that attitude i
don't know looking to go to jail ever
again
i'm never looking to get handcuffed ever
again if i got the chance you know
i don't want them touching me searching
me i want to be where i say hey wait up
man
you need to touch me dude straight up
you know i mean i want to be like that
when it's like that i'll be content you
know
but other than that like i said i gotta
have to just [ __ ] the police and i wear
it a lot
you know what i mean i get a lot of
dirty looks the other day there was one
looking at me and i'm like what the [ __ ]
is he staring at
i didn't realize i had [ __ ] the police
on my hat you know what i mean
and he's just staring at me he's a young
little [ __ ] he
he's waiting like about ten soaking wet
he was gonna do nothing
put a handcuff on maybe but you know he
was staring and i was like what the [ __ ]
is this [ __ ] cop staring at
and then i remembered i had [ __ ] the
police written across my hat and you
know
it cost me 35 hours to get that hat but
you know
i wanted to share that today with you
mark you know i'll share more
i want to you know go into a few other
things you know what i mean like
you know with my homegirls you know the
way next time when i explain it i'm
going to explain you know more or less
about
how i was out there
pushing [ __ ] and i handed people women
with me
i couldn't trust my homeboys i couldn't
trust a man a woman
oh yeah you trust him a lot more than a
man and they're going to give you your
money you know and
i want to share that next time i come in
with you you know and share that you
know about
how because you i know you got some
women that told your stories i got some
hungers that
i could tell you stories about me and
them and you know they all went to jail
for me
you know it's kind of hard to make a
woman do time but you know i want to
share that with you mark next time i
come you know
all right yeah